deine dein hack fresse sieht auch nicht
aus servus skills und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video des
dümmsten youtube es in deutschland
bremst youtube fragt ihr euch ich bin
tatsächlich diese art von youtube im
januar in dem monat wo man am wenigsten
kohle vom ganzen jahr bekommt anfängt
täglich hochzuladen und da völlig im
dezember hält man so viel geld machen
könnte man dann täglich hochgeladen
wisst ihr dann fühlt man sich schon so
richtig so denkt sich schon du bist
schon ein bisschen blöd dann geht man
auf die startseite und was sieht man da
sieben youtuber kinder die mehr
verdienen als deine eltern wollte dass
ich mich noch schlechter fühlen wegen
meines lebens ist schon schlimm genug
ich habe im januar angefangen täglich
hochzuladen
dezember nicht willst dich mit den
gleichen klicks ist dreifache verdient
und dann auch noch youtuber kinder die
mehr leute folgendermaßen warum geht
diese scheiß leiste hier und nicht weg
windows du bist doch das unnütze freut
mich wahrscheinlich warum der titel so
heißt wie er heißt und die antwort ist
ich wusste dass es käse hochgeladen hat
die münchener freiheit des internets
apa/red kann ich kopfrechnen leute das
ist wirklich eine sache die ich nicht
verstehe ich leider für so ein
alltägliches video hochladen
alltägliches video ist wirklich ein ganz
normales video ja ein video titel
einfach ab und kann dich kopf rechnet
aber selbstverständlich kann wieder
einige apotheker vorbei an sich leicht
des eigentlich ganz gut 480 discs auf
fast 16.000 likes aber die hätte
kommentare bleiben nie aus man muss
sagen abrät fanboys die leute hätten die
abo retten
die haben wirklich verdammt viel zu tun
es ist kein leichter job der welt lieber
logistik mitarbeiter bei amazon in der
weihnachtszeit als jemand der upgrade
auf youtube verteidigung super mega gala
kommt auf jeden fall das habe ich
richtig gefeiert von 2 marie bitte hier
spenden sammeln für die
zentraleuropäische wander glatze
dankeschön 2 marie dann dich kannst
deine augen das ist sagt man so oder
denn die zentraleuropäische war glatz
ist wirklich ein ernstzunehmendes
problem
und der erste kommentar wir werden uns
auch mit einem kommentar von fabio luisi
er schreibt es gebraucht wieder klicks
und was passt am besten eine reaktion
video über apa red mein lieber fabio
jeder youtuber braucht klicks jeder
youtuber würde seine eigene oma dafür
verkaufen ein klick mehr auf dem video
zu machen und ich hab schon mal gesagt
ich bin kurz davor mich nackt
auszuziehen auf die straße zu rennen
den youtuber dreht geistig vollkommen
durch und landet in der klapse prank zu
machen einfach nur für einen extra kick
auf meine videos also finde ich im
verhältnis dazu sind rost videos über
videos die man auch wirklich jetzt nicht
nur positiv auffassen kann eigentlich
doch ganz in ordnung außer [ __ ] you
dream team youtube schreibt tv entry mit
dieser moment wenn es kein über eine
frisur sich lustig macht aber aussieht
wie ein strohballen sich aus wie ein
strom heute will ich sie aus dem strom
ich würde echt wünschen von euch leute
ich würde wirklich wünschen von euch
wenn ich außer den strom macht mich
darauf aufmerksam ich möchte nicht in
strobl aussehen sollte was für ein
kommentar alter ist sogar sollte ich
jemals ein video aus gewinnstreben und
ich hoffe dass mittels cash
dann schreibt dass geräte und in die
kommentare macht mich darauf aufmerksam
damit ich zum friseur gehen kann und
nicht mehr windstrom auf see nächste
kommentar von ein paar buchstaben wo
genau hat gesagt dass rosi führung
gekostet hat in dem video die du hast du
das video nicht gesehen jason ward
studio reset und wenn sich in meinem
video drin war damals auf jeden fall
seinem original video drin robin gutzeit
schreibt hört doch auf mit dieser abo
hör auf mit was hört doch auf mit dieser
ab hör auf mit dieser apparat scheiße
der hat mehr erreicht als du macht liebe
dein ding robin gutzeit ich danke dir
für deinen kommentar schön dass du deine
meinung oder myvideo geschrieben hast
ich verstehe nur nicht so ganz denn satz
bauer vielleicht kommt auch aus einer
anderen galaxie das kann durchaus sein
dass man da so spricht hört doch auf mit
dieser ab oder auf mit dieser abwehr
weiß und zu diesem thema mach dein ding
robin gutzeit was
wenn ab und zu forschen mein ding ist
was dann
ich mache so etwas tatsächlich echt
gerne gerade wenn ich so ein video auf
dass mich so richtig triggert leute ich
habe so viel spaß bei diesem baby video
damals gehabt hab ich mein erstes
kommentar in die richtung ich habe so
viel spaß ganz viel spaß werde ich nie
wieder in meinem leben haben egal
hochzeit kinder leah vorschreibt was
laberst du so viel scheiße deine dummen
videos sind mega langweilig drei
ausrufezeichen 54 lange matches verpiss
dich aus youtube ohne o2 ausrufezeichen
dafür einen daumen nach unten
zwei lautsprecher moment mal was ist das
ist das ein schweine smiley so kleines
sparschwein und dann noch zweimal mann
der glaube ich an der mülltonne steht
lea okay ich vermisse mich freiwillig
leer wenn ich noch einmal so ein
kommentar sie zu einem ekligen images
bei der die deutsche sprache im internet
besteht zu 90 prozent aus buchstaben und
einem prozent aus images ja nicht 99
images und einem prozent buchstaben das
wirklich aus selbstanwendung mit leuten
schreibt die älter als acht jahre alt
sind aber wie gesagt einfach noch so ein
kommentar schreiben mit vielleicht
kannst du noch fünf lachs meister
nächste mal oder 6 dann ließ ich mich
aus youtube oder auch ganz kurze knapp
wie wäre es denn mit aldi will ich hasse
dich ab jetzt jetzt jetzt ohne tz jetzt
ok ali das trifft mich persönlich sehr
hart weil ich dich auch schon lange
kenne wir sind damals zusammen in den
kindergarten gegangen beste schulzeit
damals über einen beste freunde
wenn man es immer gegenseitig stein an
den kopf geworfen dass du mich jetzt
alle ich kenne ich halt nicht
was soll ich damit anfangen dass du mich
jetzt hast du schreibst mir sowas
überhaupt es gibt halt einfach nicht
tatsächlich auch so kommentare wie hier
von mohammed hier gibt es eine folge der
schlechten rapper richtig grad schon mal
vorbei nein
du wirst dreimal aus dem leben gebannt
warum gibt leute die sowas machen der
ist auch hart von wales nie sneijder
ihr seid doch alle nur neidisch lasst
ihn doch wenn er nicht kopfrechnen kann
das ist nicht euer problem deiner dein
hack fresse sieht auch nicht aus
meine adresse sieht nicht aus meint
fresse so meinhardt fresse sieht nicht
aus das kann ich so hinnehmen
sie sieht nicht aus sie sieht nicht gut
aus sieht nicht schlecht aus der sieht
einfach gar nicht aus die existiert
einfach nicht die ist optisch einfach
nicht wahrnehmbar danke für den hinweis
ich werde in zukunft darauf achten dass
ich mein gesicht optisch nicht mehr
wahrnehmen kann im spiegel hat den
kommentar sogar bearbeitet ich frag mich
was vor da stand letztlich schreibt es
gehört doch einfach mal auf upgrade zu
helfen soll als welchem er seine person
es ist nur eine person erst mal okay
also kannst mich durchaus im singular
ansprechen will doch einfach mal auf
apotheken bieten ist englisch für
erhitzen
also ich weiß nicht was ich in meiner
vorstellung gemacht habe aber ich habe
sicher nicht ab und ihr somit stabil
mäßig in bunsenbrenner unseren arsch
gehalten dann 1000 grad heisse a poor s
s p video gemacht aber leute let's play
hat auch ein bisschen wahrheit und
seiner aussage denn mir ist es gestern
aufgefallen als ich das video nach
angeschaut habt diese apa/red kommentar
ist tot
upgrade krieg schon genug scheiße aber
krieg richtig viel hängt ab und
mittlerweile hat jeder youtuber in
deutschland gefühlt drei upgrade videos
gemacht sogar bibel tv leben mit jesus
hat schon über 5 update videos gemacht
deswegen denke ich mir jetzt einfach mal
let's play du hast recht habe ich auch
gestern abend auf twitter geschrieben
war the way und zum abschluss lena meyer
schreibt ab jetzt mehr autos als du also
räder nicht in diesem sinne lena meyer
sein wunsch sei ein befehl bis zum
nächsten mal heute haut rein macht
gutzeit und ich will nicht mehr